in your lifetime will we be able to
build an ai system that's able to
replace me as the interviewer
in this conversation
in terms of ability to ask questions
that are compelling to somebody
listening and then
further question is
are we close
will we be able to build a system that
replaces you
as the interviewee
in order to create a compelling
conversation
where this podcast
sort of the fourth or the fifth time we
talk on this podcast both of us will be
uh replaced by
ai agents where that represents our
viewpoints how far away are we do you
think it's a good question um i think
partly i would say do we want that i
i really like when we start now with
very powerful models interacting with
them
and thinking of them more closer to us
the question is if you remove the human
side of the conversation is that an
interesting you know is that an
interesting artifact and i would say
probably not i've seen for instance last
time we spoke like was we were talking
about starcraft
and creating you know agents that play
games involves self-play but ultimately
what people care about was
how does this agent behave when the
opposite side is is a human
so
without a doubt we will probably be more
empowered by ai um maybe you can
source some questions from an ai system
i mean that even today i would say it's
quite plausible that with your
creativity you might actually find very
interesting questions that you can
filter we call this cherry picking
sometimes in the field of language
and likewise if i had now the tools on
my side i could say look you're asking
this interesting question
from this answer i like the words chosen
by this particular system that created a
few words
completely replacing it feels
not exactly exciting to me um although
in my lifetime i think way i mean given
the trajectory i think it's possible
that perhaps there could be interesting
um maybe self-play interviews as you
you're suggesting that would look look
or sound kind of quite interesting and
probably would advocate or you could
learn a topic through listening to one
of these interviews at a basic level at
least so you said it doesn't seem
exciting to you but what if exciting is
part of the objective function the thing
is optimized over so you can there's
probably a huge amount of data
of humans if you look correctly of
humans communicating online and there's
probably ways to measure the degree of
you know as they talk about engagement
so you can probably optimize the
question that's most
created an engaging conversation in the
past so actually if you strictly use the
word exciting
there is probably
a way to create a optimally exciting
conversations
that are involved ai systems at least
one side
is ai yeah that makes sense i think
maybe looping back a bit to to games and
the game industry when you design
algorithms um you're thinking about
winning as the objective right or the
reward function but in fact when we
discuss this with blizzard the creators
of starcraft in this case i think
what's exciting fun
if you could
measure that and optimize for that
that's probably why we play video games
or why we interact or listen or look at
cat videos or whatever on the internet
so it's true that modeling reward beyond
the obvious reward functions we've used
to in reinforcement learning is
definitely very exciting and again there
is some progress actually into um a
particular aspect of ai which is quite
critical which is um for instance is a
conversation that or is the information
truthful right so you could start trying
to evaluate um these from
except from the internet right that has
lots of information and then if you can
learn a function automated ideally so
you can also optimize it more easily
then you could actually have
conversations that optimize for
non-obvious things such as excitement
so yeah that's quite possible and then i
would say in that case it would
definitely be fun a fun exercise and
quite unique to have at least one site
that is fully driven by
an excitement reward function um but
obviously
there would be still quite a lot of
humanity in the system both from who
who is building the system of course and
also um ultimately if we think of
labeling for excitement that those
labels must come from us because it's
just
hard to
have a computational measure of
excitement as far as i understand
there's no such thing
well
as you mentioned truth also i would
actually
venture to say that excitement is easier
to label than truth
or is perhaps uh has lower consequences
of failure
but there is
perhaps
this the humanness that you mentioned
that's perhaps part of a thing that
could be labeled and that could mean
an ai system that's doing dialogue
that's doing conversations
should be
flawed for example
like that's the thing you optimize for
which is uh have inherent contradictions
by design have flaws by design
maybe it also needs to have a strong
sense of identity
so it has a backstory it told itself
that it sticks to it has memories
not in terms of the how the system is
designed but it's able to tell stories
about its past
it's able to have
um
mortality and fear of mortality in the
following way that it has an identity
and like if it says something stupid and
gets cancelled on twitter that's the end
of that system so it's not like you get
to rebrand yourself that system is
that's it so maybe that the the
high-stakes nature of it because like
you can't say anything stupid now or oil
because
uh you'll be cancelled on twitter and
that there's there's stakes to that and
then i think part of the reason that
makes it uh
interesting and then you have a
perspective like you've built up over
time that you stick with and then people
can disagree with you so holding that
perspective strongly
holding sort of a maybe a controversial
at least
a strong opinion all of those elements
it feels like they can be learned
because it feels like there's a lot of
data
on the internet of people having an
opinion
and then combine that with a metric of
excitement you can start to create
something that as opposed to trying to
optimize for uh
sort of
grammatical clarity and truthfulness
the the factual
consistency over many sentences you're
optimized for
the humanness
and there's obviously data for humanness
on the internet
so i wonder
i wonder if there's a future where
that's part
or i mean i i i sometimes wonder that
about myself i'm a huge fan of podcasts
and i listen to
some podcasts
and i think like what is interesting
about this what is compelling
uh the same way you watch other games
like you said watch play starcraft or
have magnus carlsen play chess so i'm
not a chess player so but it's still
interesting to me and what is that
that's the
the stakes of it maybe
the end of a domination of a series of
wins i don't know there's all those
elements
somehow connect to a compelling
conversation and i wonder how hard is
that to replace because ultimately all
of that connects the initial proposition
of how to test
whether an ai is intelligent or not with
the touring test
uh which i guess
my question comes from a place of the
spirit of that test
yes um i actually recall i was just
listening to our first podcast where we
discussed turing tests um so i would say
from a
neural network you know ai builder
perspective
there's
you know usually you try to map many of
these interesting topics you discuss to
to benchmarks and then also to actual
architectures on the how these systems
are currently built how they learn what
data they learn from what are they
learning right we're talking about
weights of a mathematical function and
then looking at the current state of the
game maybe
what do we
need leaps forward to get to the
ultimate stage of all these experiences
um lifetime experience of fears like
words that currently
barely we're we're seeing um progress
just because what's happening today is
you take all these human interactions um
it's a large bust of variety of human
interactions online and then you're
distilling these
sequences right going back to my passion
like sequences of words letters um
images sound there's more modalities
here to be to be at play and then you're
trying to
just learn a function that will be happy
that maximizes the the likelihood of
seeing all these um through a neural
network
now
i think there's a few
places where the way currently we train
these models would clearly like to be
able to develop the kinds of
capabilities you say
i'll tell you maybe a couple one is
the lifetime of an agent or a model
so you
you learn from this data offline right
so you're just passively observing and
maximizing these you know it's almost
like a mountains like a landscape of
mountains and then everywhere there's
data that humans interacted in this way
you're trying to make that higher and
then you know lower where there's no
data and then these models generally
don't
then experience themselves these they
just are observers right they're passive
observers of the data and then we're
putting them to then generate data when
we interact with them
but that's very limiting the experience
they actually experience um when they
could maybe be optimizing or further
optimizing the weights we're not even
doing that so to be clear and again
mapping to
alphago alpha star
we train the model and when we deploy it
um to play against humans or in this
case interact with humans um like
language models they don't even keep
training right they're not learning in
the sense of the weights that you've
learned from the data they don't keep
changing
now there's something a bit more
feels magical but it's understandable if
you're into neural nets which is well
they might not
learn in the strict sense of the words
the way it's changing maybe that's
mapping to how neurons interconnect and
how we learn over our lifetime but it's
true that
the context of the conversation that
they they that takes takes place with
when you talk to these systems it's held
in their working memory right it's
almost like um you start a computer it
has a hard drive that has a lot of
information you have access to the
internet which has probably all the
information but there's also a working
memory
where the these agents as we call them
or start calling them build upon
now this memory is very limited um i
mean right now we're talking to be
concrete about 2000 words that we hold
and then beyond that we start forgetting
what we've seen so you can see that
there's some short-term coherence
already right with when you said i mean
it's a very interesting topic um having
sort of a mapping
um an agent to like have consistency
then you know if if you say oh what's
your name um it could remember that but
then it might forget beyond 2000 words
which is not
that long of context if we think even of
these podcast um books are much longer
so
technically speaking there's a
limitation there super exciting from
people that work on deep learning to be
working on
but
i would say we lack maybe benchmarks and
the technology to have
this lifetime
like experience of memory that keeps
building up
however the way it learns offline is
clearly very powerful right so
i you know you asked me three years ago
i would say oh we're very far i think
we've seen the power of this imitation
again uh on the internet scale that has
enabled this um to
feel like at least the knowledge the
basic knowledge about the world now is
incorporated into the weights
but then this
experience is lacking and in fact as i
said we don't even train them when you
know when we're talking to them other
than
their working memory of course is
affected so that's the dynamic part but
they don't learn in the same way that
you and i have learned right when
from basically when we're born and
probably before
so lots of fascinating interesting
questions you asked there i think um the
one i mentioned is this idea of memory
and experience versus just kind of
observe the world and learn its
knowledge which i think for that i would
argue lots of recent advancements that
make me very excited about the field and
then the second
maybe issue that i see is
all these models
we train them from scratch that's
something i would have complained three
years ago or six years ago or 10 years
ago
and it feels
if we take inspiration from
how we got here how the universe evolved
us
and we keep evolving it feels
that is a missing piece that we should
not be training models from scratch um
every few months that there should be
some sort of
way in which we can grow models um much
like as a species and many other
elements in the universe is building
from the previous sort of iterations and
that from a just purely neural network
perspective
even though we we would like to make it
work it's proven very hard to not
you know throw away the previous weights
right this landscape we learn from the
data and you know refresh it with a
brand new set of weights um given
maybe a
recent snapshot of these data sets we
train on etc or even a new game we're
learning so that's
that feels like something is missing
fundamentally we might find it but it's
not very clear how it will look like
there's many ideas and it's super
exciting as well
you